scientists have proven that you can grow
potatoes on Mars that's amazing yeah
when they heard this half of America
said wait a planet with no trump and
french fries where do we go let's get
out of here
come on that deserves some coverage
right there got to do it just a little
yeah that guy was in the right you
should not have turned on him he really
shouldn't have to cut my breast in
between every jokes but thank you what
else is going on it's come out ladies
dummy a big story that Russia we all
know drush a probably tried to meddle
with our election what's come out that
Russia may have tried to undermine the
presidential campaign of Marco Rubio
yeah in other words Russia stepped back
and did nothing
okay we're good it's a it's
habit-forming speaking of Russia today
Vladimir Putin denied meddling in our
presidential election he denied it
yeah not helping was that Putin made the
statement from behind the desk in the
Oval Office
[Applause]
you know this Ivana Trump is now working
for her father did you know this yeah
president Trump's daughter Ivanka is
gonna have her own office in the White
House her own office ya know so finally
we got a woman named Trump who actually
wants to be in the White House
I'm cueing it myself now dictionary.com
has added 300 new words including
smackdown throw shade sexed and [ __ ]
face story yeah geddes announcement was
made by dictionary.com CEO a 15 year old
girl named Ashley it got enough that was
fine no that got what it deserved
hey McDonald's is in the news this
morning McDonald's announced that
beginning next year beginning next year
they will start using fresh beef in
their quarter pounders yeah yeah
then they said as for this year good
luck
you
you